[Music]
how can you be the classic starting with
the dough flour powder sugar almond
flour and salt butter blend until Sandy
texture add two eggs and blend until it
just start to combine drink
together that is rest in the frider
while working on the
jam sugar sumach lemon juice to well
beautiful let's swall out the dough
flour generously roll on the rolling pin
very gently very gently very gently
rolling it off we'll fix whatever
happened here adding our gem on top
spread evenly on the dough now the rest
of the dough we're going to roll on the
parchment paper lightly brush with egg
Sesame on top chill in the
fridge and
bake look at this beauty yes